The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today, in some
ways, that word for what
we've been suffering through
for the last few lectures
because we'll actually get to
see some optical instruments
and how they work.
So we'll basically
put all of these tools
and all of the terminology
and the matrices
and the formulas
and all that, we'll
put it to work for the basic
optical systems, namely
microscope and telescope.
And we'll also look at
sort of the building
block of a microscope
which is a magnifier lens.
But before we do
that, I would like
to spend some time just
reviewing basically
all the fundamental
material before it will go
into the application systems.
I would like to do review
the fundamental material.
So the first four
or five slides--
I don't remember.
I think five.
They're not really new.
I just brought them--
just copied them from
the previous lectures
as a kind of overview.
And I would like, instead
of just describing it again,
I would like to encourage you--
I will pass on it
and I would like
to encourage you to ask
any questions if you
have on this particular
topic or something related.
So the first topic is the
ray transfer matrices.
And again, very
briefly to remind you,
this comes about because at
a fraction at the spherical
dielectric interface is
very complex to deal with,
not the very complex.
It is actually pretty simple.
But algebraically
complicated, or I
should say trigonometrically,
very complicated.
So because we don't want
to deal with that stuff.
And it also hides a
lot of the intuition,
we derived this paraxial
approximation which
is true for a pretty limited--
typically 10 to 30 degrees.
Actually 30 is too optimistic,
maybe 10 to 20 degrees
from the optical axis.
We discovered that there
is a linear relationship
between them, elevation and
angle of a ray that is arriving
from the left to the interface.
And the elevation and angle
of propagation of array
that is departing to the
right over the interface,
the same rate, that
is [INAUDIBLE]..
And of course, the elevation
is the same because
of the paraxial
approximation, we
neglect the thickness
of the instrument.
So basically, no matter where
the ray hits, here or here
or here, it is all the same.
So that helps.
And the second is that the
angle, basically the angle
satisfies Snell's
law with respect
to the normal at this sphere
at this location over here.
But of course, because
this orientation
depends on the relative position
of the arrival of the ray
and the center of
the sphere, then we
simplified it using the
paraxial approximations.
And we discovered this
expression over here.
So the relationship between
the right and the left angle,
it has to do with the elevation.
So if you look at
this equation, it
says that n-right, alpha-right
equals n-left alpha-left.
That's the first term.
And then the interesting part
is the second one that says
equals minus this quantity
times the elevation of the ray.
So that tells you
that the more--
the higher the arrival elevation
of the ray, the more it bends.
And that makes sense because
the higher the arrival,
the larger the angle that
it makes with respect
to the normal to the sphere
and, therefore, if you wish,
the more violent the
Snell's law will be.
And of course, you can imagine,
as you increase the angle,
eventually the angle
becomes so large
that the paraxial
approximation breaks down.
But this is all true.
Before the approximation
breaks down,
the progression is linear.
It is linear in the position.
And the quantity that appears
here, does anybody remember?
How do you call this quantity?
Optical power.
Correct.
Could you please
push the button?
Correct.
It's called the optical power.
And it is actually
the first instance
that we saw this quantity.
It is the inverse
distance units.
But we don't call
it inverse meters.
We call it-- how do we call
the unit of this quantity?
Diopters, right?
AUDIENCE: So professor,
I have a quick question.
Here we have quantity
over radius r.
Does this describe a
hyperboloid or elliptical shaped
or a spherical lens?
And if so, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
AUDIENCE: For example, with the
spherical or an elliptical lens
that has two different radiuses.
How do you account for that?
PROFESSOR: So this derivation,
we actually did for a sphere.
So the radius here is the radius
of the spherical interface.
And a very similar
relationship would
hold if instead of
a sphere you had
another ovoid, another
surface of revolution which
would be symmetric around
the axis over here.
So for example, if
I put a parabola.
Imagine a parabolic bowl where
this is the cross section
of the parabola.
But then if you spin it around
this axis, it remains the same.
This is called a
paraboloid of a revolution.
This is actually-- I
believe this was a homework
or actually we'll do it
a little bit later today.
We'll discover that
a very similar--
actually in the same equation
holds, except in the case
r is not that radius
of the parabola
if the parabola does
not have a radius,
but it does have a
curvature near the axis.
So the curvature of
the parabola, actually
the inverse of the curvature
is-- the radius of curvature
is what enters this equation.
Now we discussed.
an ellipsoid.
And you are right that the
ellipsoid has two axes.
But the ellipsoid that
we saw, the two axes
are oriented a different way.
So in the ellipsoid
that we saw, when
the actual propagation
is z, then we have
one of the lateral axis is x.
And we show that the
perfect focusing element,
the perfect focusing
refractive element
is an ellipsoid looks like this.
So of course, this has
a major and minor axis.
But you can see that
the ellipsoid is still
symmetric with respect
to the optical axis.
So in other words, it is still
an ellipsoid of revolution
around the z-axis.
So I don't have to worry
about 2 radii of curvature.
But it is still a valid
question, what you are asking.
What if I did have-- what if
I do put the surface there
with [INAUDIBLE] of curvature?
Well, it turns out,
you will seldom
see this in books except basic--
I don't think I've
ever seen it in a book.
But we can reconstruct
what you should do.
This is slightly
incomplete because I'm only
dealing with elevation
of the ray and the angle
in a cross section of the plane.
And that is fine here because
it is a surface of revolution.
But if it is not a
surface of revolution,
then I have to grow
this to a 4 vector
with two angles
and two elevations.
And then this would
become a 4 by 4 matrix.
And then it would have a
different power in each axis,
depending on the
Gaussian curvature
of the surface in the
corresponding location where
the ray hits the axis.
So you can imagine it will
become a very complicated kind
of situation.
So typically we
don't deal with this.
I don't even know if optical
elements are designed this way.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CREW: Can you press
the button, please?
Oh.
You cannot hear?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I pressed it but it didn't
seem to do anything.
You can hear now?
CREW: Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was just saying
that I haven't come across this
for geometrical objects either.
But I have seen it for
diffraction optics,
in terms of the Wigner
distribution function.
And what I was going
to carry on to say,
though, was for the
geometric optics case,
it might be quite
interesting because it
would allow you to look at
the behavior of skew rays.
So it might actually give some
quite interesting information,
I think.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's true, yeah.
And you could also look at
things like caustics, right?
You know, if you make the
surface non-rotationally
symmetric, you get new
different caustics.
Forgive us.
We got into a slightly
esoteric conversation here.
But that's a really
good question.
So we may end up writing a
paper about this in a few months
or something.
Great.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Isn't this problem
separable in x and y?
PROFESSOR: Actually,
before I answer that.
Let me bring up a
trivial case where
you might have this situation.
That's a cylindrical lens.
The analysis with it is
actually valid for two cases.
One is when you have a surface
of revolution, like a sphere.
The other is if you
have a cylinder,
in which case,
everything is invariant
in the out-of-place direction.
So that's just a
trivial case where
you have a radius of
curvature in one plane.
And the curvature is--
the register is
infinite in other plane.
That is, we a plane, a
planar surface, right?
That's also called
a cylindrical lens.
And of course the cylindrical
lens does not focus to a point.
It focuses on a line.
There's no focus in here.
But you can imagine if
you focus on the line out.
I'm sorry.
So what was the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
the question was,
isn't the problem
separable in x and y.
So we could just extend
the matrix in y direction,
and [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I think that's true.
The paraxial approximation,
it is separable, yeah.
But of course, if you go off
the paraxial approximation,
things like [INAUDIBLE] and
so on, then all bets are off.
They become highly coupled.
So for example, astigmatism
is highly coupled.
You cannot [INAUDIBLE] with--
astigmatism for those of you
who are not unfortunate enough
to have it in your own
eyeglass prescription,
astigmatism is a situation where
an optical system focuses--
it's kind of difficult. I'll
go into it in next week.
It's a form of aberration
where an optical system has
different focusing properties
for tangential rays as opposed
to the sagittal rays.
I don't want to
confuse you right now.
But it is a form
of operation that
has to do with skew
rays that arrive in sort
of off-axis and off-plane.
And it is actually
very common in people.
Very often those
of us who wear--
does anybody know you
if you have astigmatism
in your prescription?
Yeah.
That's right.
Yes.
So it means that his glasses
are not exactly spherical.
Other questions?
The next step--
so this we did, I
believe it was two
weeks ago or so.
Then the next thing
that we did is
we took this formulation
basically-- oh,
and before I move on
let me just remind you
very briefly why we did this.
This looks kind of silly.
It tells you that if you have a
ray propagating in free space,
again you can relate
the elevation and angle
to the left of some
chunk of free space
to the ray elevation
and angle to the right
of that chunk of free space.
That's, again, that looks silly.
Because we know
the ray propagates
in a straight line in free space
or in uniform space because
of Fermat principle.
And of course,
what will happen is
that the angle of propagation
will remain the same.
That's what this law says.
And also the elevation
will increase
by the distance
times the tangent
of the angle of propagation.
But of course, with the
paraxial approximations,
instead of the tangent
we put the angle itself.
So this is what this
equation says here.
If you multiply this by this,
the indices of refraction
will drop out.
And you're left with d,
the distance times alpha.
So it is really the tangent.
So this seems silly.
But the reason we did
it is so that when
we have optical systems with
a cascade of uniform space
then add the refractive
interface and then more uniform
space and so on, then
you can basically
ray trace those systems simply
by cascading these matrices.
So this is why we did
this particular pattern.
But this really doesn't
say anything other
than rays must propagate
in a straight line
in uniform refractive index
because that is the shortest
path for them to follow.
And then what we did, after
we developed this formulation,
is we actually put into practice
in the special case of two
adjacent spherical surfaces.
So typically, you
have air outside.
And between the two
surfaces, you have glass.
And this kind of
element is what we call
in everyday language a lens.
It does not have to be glass.
For example, in the case of
our eyes, it's not glass.
It is actually tissue,
mostly water in fact.
But anyway, it is higher
index of refraction
than the surrounding air.
So it is acting--
it is doing the
same job as a lens.
And what we did then, if you
recall, I will not do all of it
again is but what we did is we
did a cascade of the matrices
for the two interfaces.
And based on this, we derived
the properties of this element.
And what we discovered
is the basic properties
that if you have had a ray
bundle that is arriving
from infinity, therefore
it is razor parallel,
this type of optical
element will actually
bring them to a focus.
So the rays after, they will
propagate a certain distance
after the element.
And then they will
focus to a point.
And we also derive the
other useful quantities,
we derive the elevation
of this point.
We discover that
it is proportional
to this focal distance times
the annual propagation.
And then we saw that
there's different cases
of focusing depending on
the nature of the lens.
Namely its optical power.
So positive lens will focus
the rays at a finite distance.
A negative lens will actually
cause the rays to diverge.
So they, strictly
speaking, do not focus.
But if you extend
them backwards,
then that create what is
called a virtual image.
And we will see later today
what exactly this virtual image
means and why it is an
extremely useful concept
in optical design.
For now, it appears
as an oddity.
What exactly is that?
Why did it move-- why did
it trace the rays backwards.
But today, actually, you
will see why this is useful.
The main point to
take out of here
is that the lens is acting
kind of like a lever.
So if you have--
if you imagine that you
are rotating the angle
that the rays are arriving
to the left of the lens,
then this point is
moving linearly.
It is staying on this
plane, ideally at least,
within the paraxial
approximation.
It is staying on this
plane but it is moving.
So as you rotate the angle,
the elevation changes.
And the constant of
proportionality in this change
is the focal length of the lens.
This is a very key point
to remember about lenses
and how they function.
And the other thing that
we said is that it can also
work the other way around.
If you take this
picture, the rule
is that the rays always go
from the left to the right.
It's not a rule,
it is a convention.
There's no physical law,
obviously, that says that.
But it's a convention.
But nevertheless,
there is a physical law
that says that if a light
propagates in one direction
and then you flip
the time backwards,
that is you reverse the
propagation of the light,
then the physical law actually
says that the propagation
should remain invariant.
That is if I knew that the light
propagated this way focuses,
if I turn time backwards
like these old movies
that you see where they
play the movie backwards
and you see it pass, you
know, moving towards the back.
If I did that, I would have
the rays going like this.
So this against our convention.
So that's why I flipped it here.
Now again, the rays are
going from left to right
but in this case they're
going through the focus.
What this picture is telling us
is that if you have rays that
originate at the point one
focal distance behind the lens,
then this will form
an image at infinity.
That is, the lens will
collimate this ray bundle.
And it will send the
rays out parallel at a 90
that obeys, actually
if you look at it,
is the same relationship
that was obeyed before.
With the next reminder sign.
And why did the minus
sign come about?
Everything's symmetric here
except for this annoying
minus sign.
Why has this come about?
Button.
Did you do a button?
Go to some desk, so
you have a button.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: The object
distance, is it?
PROFESSOR: Maybe
not the distance.
We have distances
and what else here?
AUDIENCE: The angle is negative.
PROFESSOR: The
angle, that's right.
The only reason
this negative sign
appears there is
the sign convention.
This angle here, we
define it as positive.
This angle here is the same.
But that's not how
we measure angles.
We always measure
angles this way.
So therefore, this
angle is negative.
So to account for
this negative angle,
a negative sign
appears over there.
AUDIENCE: I have
another quick question.
Let's say we have a lens
where our left and our right
are the same, which I believe
is pretty common in optics.
So from the lens
makers equation you
would get that
1/f is equal to 0.
PROFESSOR: Nope.
AUDIENCE: Or is that wrong?
Because you get 1
minus a quantity--
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
That's not true, actually.
If the red is to the left
is equal to the-- well,
depends how you are.
Is it like this or like this?
AUDIENCE: It's like this,
PROFESSOR: Like this?
AUDIENCE: Yes, sir.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let me give you a hint.
If it was really like
this, we have 1 and 1.
Now it is the same
radius of curvature,
and that would indeed have
no power, no optical power.
Their focal length
would be infinity
or the optical power would be 0.
In this case, are the radii
of curvature the same or not?
AUDIENCE: So one's negative
and one's positive.
Is that what you're saying?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
They're not the same.
They're opposite.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
PROFESSOR: So they may be
the same in absolute value.
But they have opposite signs.
Therefore in this
case, you actually
get a finite focal length.
I'm sorry, I don't think
you could see what I do.
Other questions?
It was a very good question.
I'm very glad you asked that.
We have to be very careful when
we apply these formulas to use
the proper sign.
So remember the curvatures
by the sign convention, which
I really recommend that you--
I don't have it available here.
But I really recommend
you go back and study it.
The convention is that if the
curvature points like this,
it is convex towards
the left, then
it is called a
positive curvature.
So in this case, you
would write, for example,
you would write r equals
maybe it is 10 centimeters.
In this case, because the
surface now is concave,
then you would say that R
equals minus 10 centimeters.
So the lens make an
equation in this case,
we'll say-- let's say n
equals 1.5 for example.
Let's make it, I would say,
1/f equals 1.5 minus 1 times
1 over 10 minus 1 over minus 10.
And this is whatever.
I believe it is 3 or something.
Wait.
This is 1/5, or
there's 0.5 times 1/5.
So it is 1 over 10 so it is 10.
Other questions?
So this was true for what
we call the thin lens, where
it is thin because we
assume that the distance
between the surfaces within
the paraxial approximation
can be neglected.
If we cannot do that, if we
cannot neglect the distance
between the two surfaces, our
formulation does not abandon
us, we just get a more
complicated formula.
And the reason the formula
becomes more complicated
is because if we drop
the approximation
of negligible
spacing then the ray
refracts twice before exiting.
It will diffract at
the first interface
and the second interface.
We'll get the formula for this.
The thick lens, I don't want
to go back into the formula.
It just comes out
of the algebra.
What I really want to
emphasize in this case
is that even though
the refracts doubly,
we can pretend that it
only refracted once.
And we can do that by
extending the incoming ray,
extending the outgoing ray.
And then what the plane,
where they intersect,
that is called the
principal plane.
Actually that is called
the second principal plane.
If I do it for an
incoming ray bundle that
is imaged at infinity then
it is the other way around.
Again, it can extend the
incoming ray, the outgoing ray,
and again get the
first principal plane.
And the reason we did
all this exercise were
to discover principal
planes and so on
is because this
allows us to do ray
tracing as shown over there.
Can you still hear me?
Sorry.
This microphone has
a tendency to fall.
OK.
You can still hear me?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Thanks.
OK.
So the reason we
did this exercise
of effective focal
length and so on
is because we can play
the following take.
I can give you an optical
system with a bunch of lenses.
I don't know, whatever.
Very complicated.
And I'm asking you to find
the imaging condition.
Here's an object.
And I'm asking you
where is the image.
What is the magnification?
Lateral, angular, and so on.
This [INAUDIBLE] of
principal planes,
it applies as we discussed
not only on a thick lens
but in general in any
compound optical system that
contains multiple
elements like this one.
And in order to utilize it,
what you do is you throw out,
so to speak, all of this
entire system and you
replace it with its
principal planes.
So here is, let's say that the
principal planes are like this.
Here's the first
principal plane,
the second principal plane.
And now I can do the imaging
business very simply.
Here's my object.
If I take a ray that goes
horizontal from the object,
this ray, it is as if
it came from infinity.
So therefore this ray will go
to the second principal plane,
it will bend.
And it will meet the axis
one effective focal length
to the right of the
second principal plane.
Then I can take
another ray which goes
through the first focal point.
That goes one focal
length to the--
I'm sorry, did I say
to the left before?
I should have said to the right.
Let me repeat.
So this ray will go--
will hit the optical
access one focal distance
to the right of the
second principal plane.
I think I said the
wrong thing before.
Anyway, to the right.
Now let me take a ray that goes
through the focal point one
focal distance to the left
of the first principal plane.
I will run out of space here.
But that's OK.
This ray will have to hit
the first principal plane
and then turn horizontal.
Because this is equivalent to a
point source one focal distance
to the left of the lens that
would be [INAUDIBLE] infinity.
So therefore, this ray
must come out horizontal.
And where these rays
meet is actually
where my image is located.
This construction is very useful
and very basic and fundamental.
And that's why the principal
planes are important.
Now let's try this.
Any questions about this?
AUDIENCE: Since we
have principal planes
for the system, are we going
to substitute the system
by a matrix which
is for single lens?
Like 1, minus 1 over f, 0.
But that's not
going to be possible
because the single lens
doesn't change the angle
but the system can change
the position and angle both.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The system is not
equivalent to a thin lens.
It's a little bit weird.
This equivalent,
you can think of it
as having two thick lenses.
One of them is
operating for this ray.
This is like a thin
lens but for this ray.
That's a bit confusing
to think of it like that.
Right?
So I so would
rather not go there.
But yeah, if you look at
the matrix of the system,
it is not a matrix
of a thin lens.
Of course not.
Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
That was actually my question.
So he's asking, what if the
focal length is negative.
How would you the ray--
this is what you're
asking, right?
Yeah.
So that was actually
my-- the next thing
I was going to do also here.
So let's take this
out of the way.
Take this out all the way too
because the marker leaked.
The marker leaked here.
Oh, OK.
We're wasting too much paper.
So let's do the same game now.
But now let's say that the
focal length is negative.
So here is an object.
And here are the two
principal planes.
Let's say this is the
first principal plane,
the second principal plane.
How would the ray
trace in this case?
Would I have a
negative focal length?
Does someone want
to help me trace it?
Button.
AUDIENCE: You first propagate
to second principal plane
and then--
PROFESSOR: So [INAUDIBLE]
the horizontal ray
to the second principal plane.
Now what?
AUDIENCE: Come back.
PROFESSOR: Come back?
AUDIENCE: In the sense
that the ray diverges
from the first plane.
PROFESSOR: But
we'll have to go--
well, why drawing's
not very good.
Let's say that this
is the focal point.
So [INAUDIBLE] diverge
in this fashion.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: What
about the other one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: First of all, where
is the first focal point?
AUDIENCE: On the right
panel [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: They cannot hear you.
AUDIENCE: Probably
should take rays
from the object to
the first focal point,
there's a back focal point.
PROFESSOR: So where is that?
AUDIENCE: That's
on the right side
of the first principal plane.
PROFESSOR: Should be
somewhere around here, right?
AUDIENCE: And at the point
where they intersect,
you make it parallel.
PROFESSOR: So this is minus f.
This is minus f.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: With the distances.
OK.
So then what do I do?
AUDIENCE: The
point where the ray
meets the first principal
plane we make it
parallel to the optical axis?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So what I have to
do is first of all
I draw a dashed line
that goes to this point.
This tells me which way
this would be pointing.
This will have to
go all the way here.
Yeah, that's right.
And then-- So
where is the image?
That's right.
The image is actually
where these rays
are supposed to meet.
Right?
They never quite meet.
But I have to extend
one of them backwards so
they would actually meet here.
And notice the
significant difference
that here the image erect.
It is upside, which is
customary for virtual images.
Whereas in this case, the image
if you recall the image quite
clearly, it was inverted.
So it is really
the same approach.
I haven't changed anything.
But the only thing I
have to do, really,
is be careful with the signs.
Who is to the left of whom.
And the way we keep track of
that and we don't lose our head
is by faithfully following
the sign conventions.
So the definition is that
the positive focal length
would be to the right of
the second principal plane.
OK.
Fine.
If I'm given a
negative focal length,
that means that I
should go to the left
of the second principal plane.
And so on and so forth.
That's the principle.
What about this case?
Can I have this?
Of course I can.
Interactive homework,
you'll see a system
that has that property.
The second principal
plane is to the left
of the first principal plane.
There's no rule or
law against that.
What we do?
Nothing changed, really.
I can still do my ray
tracing as before.
If I were to do
my rotation here,
well, it would go up to
the second principal plane.
I would shift the ray down.
Let's say this is
one focal distance.
And then now let me do
the other one correctly.
So this is the first principal
plane so to go from here--
something like that.
I mean, that produced
a ridiculously--
Well, we're here.
I did something wrong here so
the image ended up very close
to the principal plane.
But this is how you would
ray trace the system.
Any questions about the
stuff I'm doing here?
So when you're given
an optical system
it's a little bit
of a judgment call.
You have-- what happened.
Some message flashed.
Something got disconnected.
Are we still there?
CREW: Yep.
PROFESSOR: So when you
have an optical system
there is three ways
you can analyze it.
One is you can just
blindly write down
the cascade of matrices,
figure out the incoming
and an outgoing angles.
And then try to
solve it this way.
The second way is you
find the principal planes.
And then you apply one
of these techniques
that I just did on paper.
And this is another
way to analyze it.
The third way, which is
what I think [INAUDIBLE]
did in the class and was also
the supplement of your nodes
is where you take each length.
You apply the imaging condition
individually and then move on.
I will not do it again.
It's in the example
of your notes.
But it's a little bit
of a judgment call.
And sometimes it's a different
matter of preference.
Some people are very
good with matrices.
So it is just
better in that case
to just multiply the matrices
and get done with it.
The principal planes that
give you more intuition.
So I'm personally not in favor
of just blindly multiplying
matrices.
That's a little
bit mind numbing.
And also very prone to algebraic
errors because we're all human.
But this method of
principal planes,
they're a little bit less prone
to algebraic errors because
with these methods, you can
actually test your intuition.
You can see easily, whether
what you are doing is correct
or not.
Whereas you make an algebraic
mistake doing the matrix
multiplications, well,
it's very difficult
to know where it happened.
And in fact, I confess
when I wrote the supplement
to the notes which is--
I don't know if you had
the chance to see it,
but it is the same
optical system solved
with the three different ways.
You know, with first of all
with the cascade of lenses
then with matrices and
then with principal planes.
So I confess that I first did
it with a cascade of lenses.
So I took the first lens.
I imaged it.
Then I used the image
of the first lens
as objects to the second
lens and I imaged again
and I found the answer.
Then I took a plan, I
got a big cup of coffee,
I did all the algebra
of the matrices,
I actually got the
wrong result. It was not
a green with the first result.
So I went back and made it
again and finally I
got the algebra correct
and I got the two
results to agree.
But for sure, the
first thing I did it
with the cascade of
lenses was correct.
Then every time I got
a different result
with the matrices,
I knew that I was
making an algebraic mistake.
Until I finally got
the matrices to agree
with the actual result.
And I got it right.
So there reason I'm
telling you this
is because I've taught
this class for 10 years,
believe it or not.
So every time when we
do the quiz number one,
your colleagues in
the past they all
try to solve the
problem with matrices.
Because it is easier.
Matrices is a no-brainer.
You just multiply
and get the result.
About 70%-- over
all these years,
I have accurate statistics.
About 70% they get stuck
into some algebraic error.
And then they cannot solve the
problem because the measure
of this is if you get
the ray tracing wrong,
you cannot do anything.
You can not do magnification.
You can not do whatever.
So I would only
recommend the matrices
if you are really, really
sharp with algebra.
Otherwise, you're better off--
and actually overall,
I think you're
better off if you land in
the physics, which is not
what the matrices give you.
The matrices are convenient.
For example, we derived all
of these based on matrices.
But after that we should
let our intuition take over.
And not rely just on the
math, which is actually
a pretty good principle in
anything you do in engineering
but it is especially true here.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So for the focal length
that is negative,
if you retrace the rate
coming from the object
say to the center of the
first principle plane.
So this--
PROFESSOR: No, you don't
trace through center
with the principal plane, you
trace it to the focal point.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
I mean, it means that, so in
this case for the focal lens
is a positive.
So we have three [INAUDIBLE]
characteristics arrays
for the--
PROFESSOR: Oh,
you mean this ray?
AUDIENCE: So OC, ray OC.
PROFESSOR: This ray?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
So for the focal length
that is negative,
can we draw that line?
So you will find that the
intersection of those rays
would not meet the
objects you found.
PROFESSOR: Oh, it should.
It should.
If I had drawn it
properly, it should.
If you drew this ray,
if you drew this ray
and then you extend
this ray backwards,
it should still go
through my image point.
AUDIENCE: No.
It shouldn't.
PROFESSOR: You're right that
they don't meet because this
is a virtual image.
What does meet is their
extensions backwards.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I know.
But when you draw it, but--
so you see those
angle relationship.
So there--
PROFESSOR: Well, that's because
my drawing is not very good.
If I had done the
drawing properly
it shouldn't have happened.
AUDIENCE: The artwork
angle is larger than the--
larger than the angle coming--
going from the say--
I mean if you take like a
z, the angle relationship
between this one and the one--
PROFESSOR: This
one and this one.
AUDIENCE: --and the one
coming from the object
to the first focal point.
So this angle is a larger
than the array coming--
larger than the
one from the goes
to the first focal point, which
means that if you backtrack.
PROFESSOR: This
is my handwriting.
This is my handwriting.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
I see.
OK.
PROFESSOR: I forced it in
order to make them eat.
I did not make a good diagram.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I see.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I'm not very good drafter.
I'm sorry.
How do you call it?
Draftsman, right?
I'm not a very good draftsman.
OK.
So I don't want to
dwell on this too much.
But this is basically--
we already discussed this idea
that pretty much the only case
where you form a real image
that is the rays actually
do meet at the image point, is
when you have a positive lens
and you place the object to the
left of the front focal point
of that lens.
That will form a real element.
All the other combinations,
they actually form
virtual images, which means
that what is coming out
of the system is a divergent
ray, a divergent ray bundle.
Therefore they
don't really meet.
But they do meet if you
extend them backwards.
And this backwards
intersection is
what we call the virtual image.
And you can see there
is different cases here.
Sometimes the magnification
is bigger than one.
Sometimes it is less than one.
These actually,
can never remember.
Every time I have to
derive which is the case.
But anyway, all
the possibilities
can happen except, of
course, for this one
where the magnification
is always negative.
It is always inverted.
In the virtual image, the
magnification [INAUDIBLE]
it is always positive.
It is very much is erect.
OK?
Any questions about this?
Real and virtual images.
And the last thing I
wanted to remind you of
is what we did on
Monday actually.
The definitions of aperture
stops pupils, windows,
[INAUDIBLE] and margin inlays.
I really don't feel like going
through all this over again.
This is probably very
fresh in your minds.
So are there any questions
for Monday's lecture
that I can answer about this?
AUDIENCE: The term vignetting
applies to the case
when the numerical aperture
changes over the field of view.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So to exaggerate
it, suppose that you
have an optical system
where on access you
get a large acceptance angle.
But then somehow
when you go off axis,
the acceptance angle
becomes very small.
So now you compare
this with this.
Clearly, this is smaller.
That is vignetting.
AUDIENCE: And that would mean--
would that be independent
of placing an aperture stop
at the focal plane of the lens?
PROFESSOR: What you can
say about vignetting
is that it generally
happens when
you place the aperture
stop in the wrong place.
AUDIENCE: In the
wrong place, OK.
OK.
PROFESSOR: When a properly
designed optical system,
it should not happen,
yeah, at least if there's
a way to get around it.
If you construct the optical
system in a way that you cannot
place the aperture stop then
that's a badly designed optical
system.
So you generally
you try to avoid it
by placing your stops
in a strategic location.
There's no universal
rule that says
you have to place the
aperture stop there in order
to avoid the vignette It
kind of depends if you
have a multi-element system.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
If you always make sure
that we place the aperture stop
at the effective focal plane,
then the vignetting
doesn't happen?
Because the rays coming
at any angle will--
PROFESSOR: That is true for
the case of a telescope.
I'm not sure if it is true
for a general optical system.
Yeah, for a telescope
where if you place it
at the common focal point,
then yes, you have--
you minimize vignetting, yeah.
OK.
Before we break, let me go
over what we will do today.
So today we have two items
in the agenda, basically.
One of them is mirrors.
So far with that with
spherical refractive
dielectric interfaces
whenever I said anything
about kind of reflective
surfaces, like mirrors.
So we'll do that very briefly.
It is simply all we
need is a modification
of the sine conventions
and we're done.
So that's a fairly
painless topic.
There's a little bit
of terminology here
which being Greek--
actually I don't know if
being Greek makes sense.
These are archaic words.
Even in Greek, we
don't use them anymore.
But a system that uses
mirrors is called catoptric,
from the Greek--
from the ancient
Greek word for mirror.
And then if it uses only
refractive elements,
you call it dioptic.
That's also where the
term diopter comes from.
And finally, there is a
class of optical systems
that use both mirrors and
refractive lenses that
are very popular in two areas
in astronomy and lithography.
In particular, lithography.
If any of you have dealt with
semiconductor lithography,
semiconductor industry where
they make these huge machines
that write on--
write patterns on silicon
to make chips and such.
For example, [INAUDIBLE]
for his project when he does
lithography.
Typically, these
machines, they contain--
the optics are probably
taller than me.
OK, I'm not that tall.
But anyway, they are taller
than a basketball player.
And they contain typically
between 20 and 30 elements.
Some of those are mirrors some
of those are refractive lenses.
So this type of system
that contains both
is called catadioptric.
That's a mouthful.
But that's what it's called.
So there will see some
examples of such systems.
And we'll see them in the
context of the basic imaging
systems that is the magnifier
lens, the eyepiece which
is basically a magnifier,
then the microscope
uses actually two magnifiers--
the telescope which is a
slightly strange magnifier.
And finally, we'll see
different types of telescope.
Where is Le?
Le?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: This is the
answer to your question.
While you guys took a break,
I drew again a careful diagram
with the ray that you asked.
So now you see so
the red rays are
the ray traces for the case
where the lens is positive.
But the second principal
plane is to the left.
And the black lines are
the rays that go to the--
that intersect the
principal planes on axis.
So you have to be
a bit careful here.
And I've got to take myself
actually the first time
I did it.
That they-- when you
depart from here,
you have to meet the
first principal plane
at this center of the axis.
And then you start from
the second principal plane.
And you're drawing
to the image point.
And you can see there
the two black lines,
they do look sort of
parallel, don't they?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hm.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And of course,
the image is here.
AUDIENCE: Actually
it's a similar thing
but I think it's wrong.
PROFESSOR: Yes,
they are similar.
It's a little bit
difficult to see here.
It is obvious that
they're similar if you
do the case of the single lens.
Remember this diagram?
That's a really bad drawing.
But from here you can see that
they're similar triangles.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And then,
of course, when
you put the principal
planes, there's
just dead space between
the two principal planes.
But the geometrical
relationships
are similar triangles
and all that stuff,
they get presented except
you are dead space.
And in this example,
it is even worse.
The dead space is
kind of reversed.
Because they moved one principal
plane on top of the other.
You know what I mean.
I think if I attempt to express
it, I will confuse the issue.
Let me talk a little
bit about mirrors now.
So for mirrors, wherever
set of the same conventions
that is a little bit
modified with respect
to the same conventions
for refraction.
And the reason, of course, is
that when you have a reflective
surface then the
rays will indeed fall
and they will start going
from the right to the left.
So because of that
fact, then we really
have to modify our
sign conventions.
And here I put all the cases
of positive quantities.
So most of these are familiar.
The positive curvature
is the same as before.
These angles and directions
here are the same as before.
The really interesting
ones, the ones
that happen upon the reflection.
Because upon
reflection, the distance
has now become positive
if they go to their right
not to the left.
And that kind of
makes intuitive sense.
Because now it is as
if actually the best
way to make sense of this
is to simply unfold it.
So if you want to take this--
the part of what happened
after reflection,
and then found it so it could
go back for one direction.
Then these quantities would then
would indeed remain positive.
So this is the origin
of the sine conventions
for the mirrors.
So for example, why is
this angle positive?
Well, because if I
flip it the other value
down it would indeed be the same
as a positive angle over here.
Of course, this angle,
if it had happened
in a refractive system,
that would have been--
well, it would
have been forbidden
to begin with because the ray
is going from right to left.
And that's anathema.
So having said that,
I'll come back to this.
But having said that, the
next thing we would like to do
is derive a matrix
relationship for mirrors.
Now long time ago,
I think it was
in the first or
second lecture or so,
we derived the ideal mirror.
We said that if you have
rays coming from infinity
and you want to focus
them onto a single point
out here, like so, we
said that the way you
do that is with a surface,
reflective surface.
And you remember, probably,
that what the surface was.
It was a parabola.
So we wrote it in
equations here.
If you call this elevation
s, you call this axis x.
So we found the
equation of the parabola
was s equals x squared
over 4F, where F is
the focal length of the lens.
So the parabola is ideal.
But in some cases, people
make spherical mirrors.
Actually, it is not
as common as lenses.
Lenses are very
commonly spherical.
Mirrors are very often actually
paraboloidal, very close
to ideal, especially mirrors
used in concentrators, things
like satellite antennas,
solar concentrations that
are used in solar energy
systems and so on.
Then, because they
would want to focus
the light on a single
point then you actually
go for the parabola.
It turns out, if you want to
form a sort of a bigger image
here than the parabola
is not very good.
So people actually
make spherical mirrors.
So for a spherical
mirror, I did a little bit
of a derivation here
which basically follows
the paraxial
approximation to connect
the ideal parabolic shape
and the focal length
that we get from the parabola
to the equivalent sphere.
And again, the parabola
and the sphere, they
kind of look the same.
If you look at the parabola,
maybe it goes like this.
If you look at the
sphere, and you
match the curvatures near the
center, it might go like this.
So what we're
trying to find here,
what is the radius
of this sphere here
that matches best the
parabola, the ideal parabola.
So this is the ideal parabola
that is given by this equation.
And then here's the sphere.
That's not a very
good looking sphere.
But anyway, let's
call it a sphere.
And the question is,
what is the radius
of curvature of this
sphere that will
match the parabola ideally.
So this is what I did here.
If you write the
equation for the sphere,
well, we know-- actually,
let me leave this up.
We know how to read the
question for the sphere.
In my chosen system of
coordinates, this is x.
And this is the positive axis z.
So the equation for the
sphere is x plus the radius,
squared plus s squared
equals the radius squared.
So this is the question
for this sphere.
This is this displacement here,
with respect to the center
of the coordinates.
And then what do you
do, this is [INAUDIBLE]
slide but I will
actually derive it
for you here so you can see it
in this sort of animated form.
And then what you
do is you actually
solve, so you have an s
equals plus/minus R minus--
what am I doing?
AUDIENCE: So you've got
your axis-- your [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
Yes, I did.
Didn't I?
Yay.
I'm sorry about that.
I think I better do this over.
So this is s for the parabola.
This is s for the sphere.
So of course it would be s
plus R squared plus x squared
equals R squared.
So that means that s equals
minus R plus minus square root
R squared minus x squared.
Now which signs would I
keep, the plus or the minus?
Well, the minus sign, you can
see a little bit by inspection,
the minus sign is this
part of the sphere which
is pretty far from the paraxial
approximation, clearly, right?
So the only way to deal with
a paraxial approximation
is to keep the plus sign.
So we'll write, then, s equals
minus R plus the next step you
do to derive paraxial
approximations
is you pull a large quantity
out of the square root.
So the large quantities,
the radius here,
and you write it like this.
1 minus x squared
over R squared.
Then you apply a Taylor formula
that says that square root of 1
plus small approximately equals
1 plus the small divided by 2.
And note, of course,
that applies also
for a negative sign.
So I can do like this.
And this means that s equals
minus R plus R 1 minus x
square over 2R squared.
And if you do it
carefully here you
see that this kills the square.
This kills this.
And you end up with s equals
minus x squared over 2R.
And what this means now is
if you compare with equation
of the ideal parabola,
which was x squared over 4F,
it means that F
equals minus R over 2.
The next question now
is what does this mean.
Is the focal length
negative or positive?
To answer this question,
we have to first remember
our sign conventions.
Is our surface
positive or negative?
That is, is R a negative
or positive quantity?
So if you recall, I'll go back
one slide to the previous one.
This is a positive curvature.
if If it is pointing that way,
I will not use any formal term
because that may be confusing.
If it's like that,
it's positive.
This is not like that.
It's the opposite.
And so therefore
here, R is negative.
So you have a negative sign
that came out of the math.
But R is a negative quantity.
So therefore F is
still positive.
So this is still
a positive lens.
And it is clear that
it is a positive lens,
because it forms a real image
for an object at infinity.
By construction, we demanded
that if I have parallel rays
from infinity, these
things should focus them
to a real point on the axis.
So therefore,
clearly, this is what
you would call a positive lens.
And since the lens,
it actually has
a matrix that is very similar
to the matrix of a lens,
all you have to do is
substitute the focal length
with the equation
that we just derived
for the radius of curvature.
And this is the matrix that
describes a mirror, a mirror
concentrator.
And of course, since it is a
lens, it also forms images.
So notice here,
the way I drew it,
these quantities are
still all positive.
Of course, it's not as positive
because I go from the object
to the right, towards
the instrument.
Now notice what happens.
From the instrument, I go to
the left towards the image.
But that is still
a positive quantity
because there was a reflection
that occurred there.
So therefore s sub I is
still a positive quantity.
So I can write this equation
with a clear conscience,
so to speak, that s0 and si
are all positive qualities.
Now can you imagine when a lens
might form a virtual image?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
Yes, a mirror.
So clearly the mirror here
is forming a real image.
Can you imagine how I could
construct a mirror forming
a virtual image?
AUDIENCE: If the mirror
diverges and you are looking
from the same side, then.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's one way.
If you make the
mirror like this,
now the mirror has a
positive R therefore
it has a negative
F. Now this mirror
has become the equivalent
of a negative lens.
Therefore it will
form a virtual image.
What's another possibility
for forming a virtual image
with a mirror?
What about a positive lens?
Could a positive lens
ever form a virtual image?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
If you put the object in
between the focal point
and the mirror itself, again,
it will form a virtual image.
That's actually a very funny
to observe by yourself.
You cannot quite do it with
a spoon because the spoon is
really too small.
You have to go really close.
And you cannot focus
your eyes in there.
But those of you
who've been at hotels--
I've never seen this in a home.
But most hotels, in the bathroom
they have a curved mirror.
And I don't want
to speculate why
they put that curved mirror,
there but anyway they have it.
And this mirror is
very lightly curved.
It has a very long
radius of curvature.
So it is very easy,
actually, if you
stand in front of the mirror,
you can move back and forth.
And you can switch your
image from real to virtual.
It is really spectacular.
It is worth checking yourself
in the Ritz Carlton in Boston
spend $400 for a night
just to see that, actually.
Because it's very, very
instructive from the optics
point of view.
But real, it's nice, because
as you go near the mirror,
basically when you get
between the focal length
and the mirror, then you see
an erect image of yourself that
is virtual because you see
yourself behind the mirror
it is magnified.
Actually, the
magnification is so high
that you typically
only see your eye.
But anyway, something like that.
If you move back, then
you see yourself inverted,
as you see yourself in
a spoon, by the way.
If you look at
yourself in a spoon
you almost always see yourself
inverted because the spoon has
a very short focal length.
So you are always
in this scenario
when you look at a spoon.
Any questions?
There's not much else to
say about mirrors really.
The same optics applies,
with this little twist
of the flipping of the
signs upon inversion.
So if you face a situation, all
you need to do is keep cool.
Don't let yourself
panic or anything.
It's just a matter
of keeping track
of the positive things that
happen to the right or to the--
I'm sorry-- to the
[INAUDIBLE] things
that happen after reflection.
And typically with
the kind of problems
that we have to solve by
hand, these are pretty simple.
I mean at most, you might
encounter one reflection.
Now people who make
optical design software,
they have to deal with arbitrary
numbers of reflections.
I wouldn't want to
be the programmer who
has to solve that problem.
Because you know, if you
have a second reflection,
then the signs flip again.
As you can imagine, if I
stick another mirror here.
So the light starts
sort of zig zagging,
every reflection flips the signs
in the sign convention again.
So it can get a bit
tricky to keep track
of all of these flippings.
But we don't have
to worry about that
at this introductory level.
So let me move onto
the next topic, which
is a few examples
of optical systems.
AUDIENCE: Hey, George.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry to interrupt.
I'm going to pass around
these parabolic reflecters
so you can try that.
PROFESSOR: Good idea.
So maybe you don't have to
go to a hotel after all.
[INAUDIBLE] What is the focal
length of this, you know?
AUDIENCE: It's like
20 centimeters or so.
You can check it out.
PROFESSOR: Great.
So yeah, you try to go
at 40 and 10 or whatever,
and you will see the difference.
It's actually quite dramatic
and very interesting.
So the magnifier, as
the name suggests,
it is a device that we use
to aid our eyes when we're
looking at a very small object.
And this is a--
dog it took me a lot of
time to make this cartoon.
So I'm very proud of it.
So let me start
the animation here.
So if you have a really
small object, of course
it will form a very small
image on your retina.
And very often,
this image is not
big enough to observe
with sufficient detail.
So the obvious
thing that you would
do if something
looks small to you
and you'd like to
make it bigger,
you don't have to
know any optics.
What you do is you
bring it near your eyes.
But from experience,
you know that this
doesn't work very well.
Because if you
exceed the distance
of approximately 25
centimeters, then you
can really not focus anymore.
And actually for you
guys who are young
it's about 25 centimeters.
As we grow older, this distance
becomes longer and longer.
And we basically
lose our ability
to focus, which is a very
annoying, annoying thing
actually.
It has just started
to happen to me.
As I approach age 40, I've
started noticing that I cannot
focus as well as I used to.
So it's a little bit annoying.
But anyway it beats the
alternative I guess.
So I'm very happy that
I reached that age.
But anyway, the point is
that there comes a point--
actually for me now,
the only way to focus
is to take off my glasses.
But even so, there
comes a point where
you can not focus anymore.
Even you cannot focus.
I bring something to 5 or 10
centimeters, you cannot focus.
The question is,
what could you do.
So what you do is
you use a magnifier.
And the magnifier is
something that you
put between the
object and your eye.
And the way it
works is like this.
We can do some simple
ray tracing here.
This is where the
parameters of the magnifier,
let's say it is a positive
lens, the magnifier.
Let's say the focal
length is F and the power
is the inverse of that.
So this is some ray tracing
that shows how the image is
formed by this lens.
So all you do is you
take a horizontal ray.
This will go somehow through--
this guy will bend it.
And let's pretend now that
this ray, somehow I tune things
so that this ray went through
the center of the eye.
So this ray went
and bend, right?
But you can see very clearly
now because what these lines did
is it bent this ray
bundle so that it
meets the object over here.
The result is that I got a much
magnified image on the retina.
That's about it.
That's all there is to.
By using this element,
you can get bigger images.
Now if I didn't
have the eye here,
this is actually the
most instructive thing
I'm going to say today.
This is really the meaning
of the virtual image.
If I give you this system
by itself, obviously
because this lens, if
you look carefully,
it created a
divergent ray bundle.
Obviously this object is between
the focal point of the lens.
So therefore, this
is the situation
that we encountered before.
And we've said that the
system forms a virtual image.
Well what is the virtual image?
I have to take these rays
that the lens produced
and I have to extend
them backwards.
And with a little
bit of manipulation
here, because this is a cartoon,
it is not a real calculation.
But with some
manipulation, I made sure
that the rays do meet.
So the rays meet.
And the point where the rays
meet is the virtual image.
There's nothing there.
Nothing.
The object is here.
The only physical entity
is here and your eye,
and the lens of course.
There's nothing here.
But when your eye
forms an image it
is as if you could
take this away--
you could take away the
combination of the object
and the magnifier and replace
it with a virtual image
that this system formed.
This virtual element is acting
as an object for your eye.
The eye images this object.
And because this object
has been magnified relative
to the actual object, you end
up observing a magnified image.
So this is the significance
of virtual images.
By themselves, that
don't mean anything.
But because at the end of an
optical system you always have
the observer's--
I mean, the
observer's eye length
and the retina,
the virtual image
ends up becoming a real image,
hopefully on the retina.
If it becomes a real
image elsewhere,
you will not be able to see it.
It will be out to focus.
Or even worse, if you
create a virtual image
and you send it to an
observer so it becomes
a virtual image on
the retina, again you
don't see anything there.
Because you can never
observe a virtual image
unless you can image it
using the optics of your eye.
So this is the
significance then.
And we'll see in the second
that everything-- microscopes,
telescopes, magnifiers--
they all form of virtual images
which eventually the observer's
eye lens converts to a
real image on the retina.
The next thing that
we'll do now is
we'll put some math
around this topic.
And this is a little
bit unfortunate
because the book is generally
very good, the textbook
that we have, Hecht.
I do think that in
this particular topic,
the textbook is a
little bit confusing.
So I'll try to walk you through
the derivation in the textbook
and hopefully I will
make it less confusing.
But if, when you go back home
and you read the textbook,
you confused again, please
bring your questions on Monday
so we can talk about this again.
So I tried to make
it less confusing
but still I'm using the
notation in the book.
So you don't-- in addition
to the confusion in the book,
you don't have to overcome
notational confusion.
So the definition of the
magnifying power which cannot
be argued against because it is
a definition is it is the ratio
of the angle subtended by
the tip of the object before
and after magnification.
Actually the subscript
here, U and A, U
stands for Unaided, that is
the eye without the magnifier.
And A stands for Aided.
That is the eye with the
aid of the magnifier lens.
And now we need to place symbols
to all of these distances here.
And I think this is where
the book is a bit confusing.
Because it tries to
do everything at once.
But anyway, so I
need this symbol
for the distance between
the object of the lens.
Then I need the symbol
from the lens to the eye.
And in the symbol from the lens
to the virtual image, which
is of course si,
and in this case
you would expect
the side to turn out
to be a negative number,
because it is a virtual image.
And finally you use the
symbol L for the distance
between the virtual
image and the eye.
So L is, of course, that simply
the sum of these two distances
with a proper sign convention.
The first thing to note
is that you don't really
need all these notations
because the magnifying power is
very simple to calculate.
As we did in the past,
all you have to do
is use similar triangles.
Because you can see that
the magnifying power--
the angle a sub a,
the [INAUDIBLE] angle,
equals the ratio of the size
of the virtual image over what?
Look at the red line.
From this ray angle,
over the big distance L.
And of course there's a tangent.
I should have a tangent there.
But I dropped the
tangent because
of the paraxial approximation.
Similarly for the
unaided eye, it
equals the ratio of the
natural height of the object
to the distance between
the object and the lens.
Now for the unaided case, the
convention is to use the near
point of the eye, that is the
25 centimeter distance beyond
which the eye cannot focus.
Because presumably,
if you wanted
to get the maximum possible
unaided magnification,
you really have to
bring the object
within this 25 centimeters.
So that's why we use d0.
So that's a standard actually.
It is 25 centimeters.
And when you play
around with this,
you discover that it equals
the ratio of these two
distances, which is easy to do.
And this is what
we used to call--
what did we call
this quantity when
we did the imaging condition?
Button.
AUDIENCE: Lateral magnification.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
This is what we used to call
the lateral magnification.
It is the ratio of
the size of the image
over the size of the object.
So this is what they say here.
And of course this is the
lateral magnification.
We have the questions
for it in terms
of the image and distances.
And we can substitute
these equations
and we can actually
derive a number
of equivalent expressions
for the magnifying power.
So now, none of this is
particularly intuitive.
And then the book goes
ahead and gives two
possible uses of
the magnifying lens
that are not particularly
intuitive either.
So I will not even
bother to deal with them.
One of them is when
you put the magnifier
one focal distance away.
I don't know if it's
necessary to do that.
The other is when you
put the magnifier--
you stick it to your eye,
which is not a very good idea
because there's
all kinds of germs
around so you don't
want to stick magnifiers
onto your body.
The way we use
magnifiers in general
is the number three
description of the book, which
is why we place the
object at one focal point
behind the magnifier.
So if the magnifying focal
length is 5 centimeters--
actually, that's a pretty long.
But anyway, you place it 5
centimeters from the object.
What do you accomplish this way?
What happens if you place an
object at one focal distance
in front of the lens.
That's right.
You form an image at infinity.
Actually, in that case, you
form a real image with infinity.
Now is that good or bad?
In the context here, you
form the image with infinity
and you still have an
observer with his or her eye
lens and the retina.
Let me draw this.
Now we draw the specific case,
according to the book lingo,
this is case number
three, si equals F.
So what does it look like?
Here's my magnifier.
Here is my eye lens.
And of course the eye
kind of looks like this.
And this is the retina.
And here is the optical axis.
And here is the object.
So let's look at the
tip of the object.
Since it is one focal
distance away from the lens
I will get a
parallel ray bundle.
Is that good or bad?
AUDIENCE: It's s0
equals F, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Thank you.
So is that good or bad?
AUDIENCE: If we talk of
aberrations, it's good.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Let's not go into aberrations.
In our simple
geometrical optics,
is that situation happy?
Are we happy that we did this?
We're happy for a
number of reasons.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Because it will perfectly
focus at the point.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
First of all, this is assumed
to be a corrected eye.
So if it was me, that would
be me wearing my eyeglasses.
If it is me without my
eyeglasses, I have a problem.
You'll see in a
second what problem.
But if it is a
healthy eyesight where
the eye can focus
perfectly, then this indeed
will form an image
on the retina.
What is the other good
news about this situation?
The fact that the
image is at infinity,
is this good news or bad news?
AUDIENCE: Your eyes remain--
your eye remains unaccommodated.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
We learned that the eye is
most relaxed when it observes
remote objects at infinity.
The reason it cannot focus
closer is because I have
to strain the lens of my eye.
And as I get older, my ability
to strain it diminishes.
But this is true for
everybody, young or old.
When you try to look
at something close by,
you get tired.
If you read a book like
this, your parents probably
told you-- they told me.
Don't read the book like
this, you get the headache.
And indeed you do.
If you read for a long time you
get a headache from very close.
So the reason this
is a happy situation
is because the eye
can be totally relaxed
as if it was observing
something very far away
and still see the object
with magnification.
And how much is
the magnification?
Well, we'll skip the math.
The math is fairly simple here.
But it turns out to be simply
the product of the near point,
the 25 centimeters, times
their power of the lens.
And the only penalty
you pay, the reason,
actually, the book covers
this case over here
is because this is not the
maximum magnification you
can get with a magnifier.
You can get slightly higher
if you stick the magnifier
next to your eye.
But you never stick the
magnifier to your eye,
actually.
Unless you're adventurous.
If I did this, I would
damage my glasses.
So the message,
perhaps, important.
But what I really hope
that you get out of this
is the significance
of the virtual image
and why the magnifier functions
by forming a virtual image that
is erect and magnified.
And this also tells you why
you will use a positive lens
as a magnifier.
If you recall, it is actually
one of the previous slides.
A negative lens also
forms a virtual image.
But unfortunately,
it is not magnified.
The magnification,
it is de-magnified.
The lateral magnification
is less than 1.
So we would be out
of luck in this case.
The next element is
actually the same.
It is no different
than the magnifier.
But it comes under
the name eyepiece
because in optical instruments
such as binoculars, telescopes,
microscopes, and the like
this is the last lens
that you look into the
instrument with your naked eye.
Now I realize that this
is old fashioned talk.
Modern instruments, you seldom
look at with a naked eye.
You actually have a camera.
So you put a digital camera
and you register the image
digitally.
However, even a digital camera
functions like a retina.
So in other words,
even a digital camera
would have an eyepiece
and then a condenser.
And then it would
go onto the chip.
So really the situation here
applies to digital imaging
as well as human, as
well as instruments
meant to be used by humans.
So the eyepiece is basically the
last element in the instrument,
just before you get to the
actual observation stage.
And because the eyepieces
were traditionally
designed for the humans,
they are typically
designed like a magnifier
with the same principle
that I described before that
forms an image of infinity.
So therefore the
observer, when he or she
looks into the eyepiece, they
can use an unaccommodated eye
and observe the magnified
image without having
to strain their eyes.
So this is the sort of
standard use of an eyepiece.
And there's a second condition
for the eyepiece which
will become a little bit more
apparent in the next slide
when I talk about
the microscope.
It is this one over here.
This looks a little bit cryptic.
It says the center of
the exit pupil eyepoint
where the observer's eye
is placed at 10 millimeters
from the instrument.
This doesn't mean much.
But I will describe what
this means in a second, when
I talk about the microscope.
Not withstanding this last
point over here, any questions
about the eyepiece or
the magnifier or anything
of that sort?
AUDIENCE: Why is the eye
[INAUDIBLE] 10 millimeter when
we cannot see?
PROFESSOR: OK.
What this really means is that
10 millimeters is the design
distance that you're supposed
to place your eyes with respect
to the instrument.
When you look at the microscope,
for example, most people
don't do that.
But you're supposed to be
at about 10 centimeters
from the last surface, right?
So that is called
the eye relief.
And what this is really saying
is that when you look at this,
you're not supposed to see
any blockage of the image.
And you're not supposed
to see vignetting.
There's two things
that can happen.
If you place your eye at the
wrong point-- as you know,
if any of you have
looked at a microscope,
if you are not positioned
properly you cannot see
the entire field of view.
That's one problem.
You see a black hole.
And you kind of
have to move around
and you can never see
anything until you
go to the proper place and then
finally you see everything.
So this is the eye relief.
This is by design where
you should place your eye.
The other thing that
can happen if you place
your eye at the wrong place
or if the microscope is not
properly designed is vignetting.
So this requirement
clearly assures
that there's no vignetting
when your eye is placed
at eye relief distance,
that is at 10 millimeters
from the instrument.
And of course, you
don't have to worry
about focusing because the
microscope is supposed to have
infinite conjugate, right?
So you just use with
an accommodated eye.
And I suspect, I don't
know if it's true,
but I suspect-- there are
many reasons why they put over
there.
But also, it's kind of
convenient that when you look
at the microscope you're so
close to the microscope tube
itself that you cannot focus
and you cannot see that.
So you can basically
see what you're
supposed to observe but you
don't see the actual instrument
because it is out of focus.
So that's kind of convenient.
So [INAUDIBLE] this
about the microscope.
Here is a microscope.
Here's what it looks like.
It is deceptively simple.
Because there's, of course,
a lot of engineering design
that goes into making
all of these elements.
But the principle is
surprisingly simple.
It consists of basically
two magnifiers.
One of them is called objective.
The other is called eyepiece.
But they both function
as magnifiers.
So the job of the objective,
this is the first lens.
It is called objective because
it is placed near the object.
And its job is basically to
form an intermediate image that
is magnified to begin with.
What is it magnified by?
Well, here we simply have--
actually this is a real image.
So we simply have a positive
lens forming a real image.
We can compute
the magnification.
It is equal to minus si over s0,
just like the regular formula.
And then we have the
eyepiece for which
the image that the objective
produced actually now
acts as the object.
So this intermediate image
is re-imaged by the eyepiece.
But the eyepiece is
placed one focal distance.
F sub e here is the focal
length of the eyepiece.
It is one focal distance
from that intermediate image.
And therefore the final
image is formed at infinity.
Now the way this is
drawn for this one, what
is prominent in this picture
is, of course, the on-axis ray.
And there's no
magnification to talk about
because this is just an axis.
Nothing interesting
is happening.
What is really
interesting is if you
look at an off-axis point,
which is at the bottom here.
It's a little bit
difficult to see.
It looks better in
the book actually.
So if you trace
this off-axis point,
then you find that
its final image
is this ray bundle
that is coming off-axis
into your eye,
this parallel ray.
That is the final image
of the microscope produced
of this off-axis
objective point.
You can see it has entered
the eye at a very large angle.
Therefore it will
form a big image.
So that's how the microscope
magnifies small objects
so that you can observe them.
So then the magnification
of the microscope,
very similar to the
case of the objective,
is defined as the ratio
of this angle, the angle
that the microscope produced
for the off-axis object,
for the same angle that the
eye would observe unaided,
in a very similar
case as the magnifier.
So in order to compute this now,
it's not very difficult to do.
We need two elements.
One is the lateral
magnification of the objective.
Because recall, the objective
actually forms a real image.
So we have one.
Here is the object.
And here is its image.
So we need, first
of all, to find out
where the intermediate
image appears with respect
to the optical axis.
That's the lateral
magnification of the objective.
That is whatever.
Well, I will say in the
second why this 160 appears.
But the second
element that we need
is the angular magnification
of the eyepiece.
Because this will allow us to
say how this distance over here
translates into angle that
goes into the eye finally.
So this one is actually
a familiar formula.
This is the same formula
you had for the magnifier.
So go back one.
We said that-- actually,
it is over here already.
We said that the
magnifying power
of an eyepiece or a magnifier
equals the near distance
for the eye, which is about 25
centimeters, times the power
of the lens, of the
positive lens that they use.
So this is the same formula.
In microscopes, they don't
use exactly 25 centimeters.
They use 25.4 centimeters.
So this is the standard.
And how much is that in inches?
Is it 10 inches?
No.
11, 12 inches.
10 inches.
I thought it would be
22-- oh, that's pounds.
I'm sorry.
That's pounds.
There's 10 inches then.
So this is, then,
the same formula
that we had for the magnifier.
Where did this come from?
Well, if you remember
one of the ways
to add the lateral
magnification is like this--
1 minus si over F. So you
can write this as 1 minus si
over F equals F minus si
over F. And now I have to--
Ah, that worked.
So minus si--
I am sorry.
It is F minus si
over F. So F minus si
is actually the distance between
the objective lens and the--
it's basically this
distance L. That's
what I'm trying to get to.
So this is known as the tube
length of the microscope.
It is the distance between the
objective lens and the location
where you put the eyepiece.
Of course, the eyepiece
is this whole thing.
So that's where you
stick the eyepiece.
So this is standard.
In microscopes, it
is 160 millimeters
and is known as the tube length.
And this is what appears
in this formula over here.
So basically, you can see that
if you pick the focal length
to be sufficiently
small, then you
can get very high magnification
in the order of hundreds, maybe
even 1,000.
Let me ask two questions now.
First of all, what I just said.
What do you think might stop
me from getting a focal length
that is, let's say, 1 micron?
I pick a focal length to be
1 micron, and then I have--
these are all in millimeters.
So 160 millimeters over 1
micron, that would be what?
That would be about 160,000.
And then another micron here,
I would get a magnification
in the order of 1 billion.
What stops me from doing that?
First of all, just
to get back to,
what is it from your experience?
What is a typical magnification
that you get in microscopes?
How about 1,000
orders of magnitude?
But if you apply
this formula here,
you could easily get a
magnification of 1 billion
by picking the focal
length to be 1 micron.
What is wrong with my statement?
Clearly, there's wrong.
Otherwise, people
would be doing it.
AUDIENCE: Is it
because you can't see
past the wave length of light?
That 1 micron is
the most you could
focus because that's the--
PROFESSOR: That is in the
correct direction, yes.
The other possible
reason is the failure
of the paraxial approximation.
But the paraxial approximation
may fail all at once.
But I can always do something
more sophisticated to do
non-paraxial calculations.
Maybe you're saying that if the
paraxial approximation fails,
then this formula fails as well.
So then you don't get
as good magnification.
I think you guys both
captured-- the two of you
captured the answer in its
entirety You have another one?
AUDIENCE: I don't
know if it's another.
To make such a high--
such a short focal
length lens we'll
have to make a very big lens.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So you have to be
very highly curved.
Remember the focal
length of the lens
is proportional to the
radius of curvature.
So you would have to
make a lens with a radius
of curvature equal to 1 micron.
And that's when you get
into problems like the--
what's your name again?
[INAUDIBLE] answered
the question before.
AUDIENCE: Dean.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is what Dean answered.
If you try to make a curvature
that is as sharp as 1 micron,
then basically you
get into the range
of very strong
diffraction of light.
So basically all
these geometrical
optics that we do
here, they fail.
In fact, you discover if you did
make such a very small element
that the light does
not really focus.
We'll see what it does.
But it does not propagate.
So reasonable focal lengths are
in the range of 1 centimeter,
a few millimeters.
These are typical microscope
objective focal length.
And the eyepieces are similar.
And that's why you
get magnification
on the order of 1,000.
The next topic is the telescope.
But I think I've
exhausted your endurance.